hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hardware unboxing video and uh it's kind
of an awkward size box here but today
we're going to be unboxing a product
from blue lounge and you can go ahead
and check out the link to this product
the cable box in the description of this
video
which should be down below if you
haven't already heard of the cable box
i'm going to say right at the beginning
of this video this is a product you're
going to want to pick up if you're
looking uh to start or create a very
professional looking workspace what i
mean by that is this product has won
several design awards which is very cool
so this has been this is a blue lounge
unboxing so if you guys want to check it
out the before and after pictures for
this are absolutely amazing now if
you're confused when i say that this is
a box that will actually
house all the cables
and your ups or your power strip
and that will definitely give your under
even underneath your desk a much cleaner
look
whether or not you ever look there if
you have a clear glass desk this will
definitely help your case
so again this is something you're going
to want to pick up if you're looking to
create a very professional looking
desktop working atmosphere
so this is the white cable box it comes
in two colors in white and in black and
i'll of course show you this later also
looks like they've included the cable
drops which are multi-purpose cable
clips which i'll also be reviewing later
um later on my channel but these are
very cool just go on your desktop and
hold like something like a usb cable
that's not in use
and you might want to check that out so
i'll include both links in the
description but what we're really
checking out in this video
is the uh the cable box so as you can
see on the side this is perfect for
fitting something like
a power strip which may have eight ten
twelve power things going through there
your laptop your desktop your microphone
all your powered accessories and just
streamline it down to make it look very
very nice underneath your desk and fit
with the theme of your desk so what i'm
going to do is go ahead and write and
cut this right open and just go ahead
and see what it looks like what it feels
like this is not a review video but
we're going to be taking a much deeper
look at this in the near future on the
mkdhd channel
let's go ahead and take a look
and i like the feel of this first of all
oops and i'll show you the bottom of it
uh what you get so this has a nice
little plastic feel but it doesn't feel
cheap i'll tell you that it does feel
solid
on the bottom you have two very large
tacky surfaces along with some
instructions on how to use it
which is cool as you can also put things
on top of the the cable box that may
match it maybe your wireless router or
your receiver
actually fits on top of it so you also
gain some space from this this is good
for single narrow power strips or the
double wide power strips and this is
actually a very good example of the
power strip i do have
so
i'm just showing you this a lot more in
action see if i can take this off and
open it up for you
uh see if we can do this here
on camera
this might
destroy the box but this is definitely
very cool no need to unplug anything all
you have to do is open up the top of the
cable box put all your cables into it
and close it up so like i said a very
nice cool design the blue lounge logo
down here on the bottom hand corner and
a very clean design now what i'm going
to do is open up the top of the cable
box see if i can show you what's in it
there's a hole on that side for your
cables and a hole on the other side for
the cables so all you have to do to open
it
is just take this side
and pull it straight up
the top comes off
what you have are your instructions and
the cable box itself so here you can
have all your wires all your uh your
before and after things
you can check out like i said the before
and after photos which look really
really good at the blue lounge website
in the description of this video
so that has been the quick unboxing of
the blue lounge cable box and uh they
even threw in the cable ties as a
surprise which i'll be reviewing very
much in in the near future
but i do highly advise you guys to check
this out so thanks for watching this
unboxing this blue lounge unboxing of an
award-winning product and i'll talk to
you guys in the near future thanks for
watching peace